These are the sounds of
the mighty sperm whale.
There's clear structure in how
these animals communicate.
We just don't yet know what they'resaying.
Our team of AI specialists, roboticists,
linguists and marine biologists
aim to use themost
cutting-edge technologies
to make contact with another species,
We're going to put specific
focus on the interactions
of mothers and calfs,
training our machine learning algorithms to
learn whale language from the bottom up.
The raw audio and context data
will go through our
machine learning engine
where it's going to be first
sorted by structure.
The linguistics teamwill
then search for things like
syntax and time displacement.
And once we've really masteredlistening,
we're going to try really carefully
to talk back even on the
mostsimplistic level.
And all the platforms that we develop can be
cross-applied to other animals:
to elephants, birds, primates,dolphins --
essentially any animal.